adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you Michael
Jackson even got his winning only homie
Kevin you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him singing Tony Tony Toni
Braxton and y'all wanna talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
incident mama got handsome and Bradford
attention imma leave them red you can
dance in Redemption
[ __ ]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents no featured event of the
evening
tonight
's out can't talk hit me with a light
job my win might lose or my drug
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I deserve for another
note
Redemption
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to another combat talk
with the professional fan the King was
going on people
what are we doing tonight
oh we got Gary Russell right now
um the youngest one the one in uh the
bantamweight division he's fighting
Rodriguez right now for the title
Eliminator for the battle weight uh
title so I think it's the ibf right now
so Gary Russell just got knocked down
now this is not Gary Russell Jr remember
the whole family uh all all the sons is
Gary Russell named after the father so
the only one that's a junior is Gary
Russell Jr that fights in um the 130 or
135 division
or the lightweight division but we have
a bantamweight which name is Gary
Russell and uh he just got dropped by
Rodriguez at the end of uh I think that
was the the eighth round
really heating up stuff uh really high
level uh boxing really good stuff I
wasn't even gonna cover
this undercar I did want to see this
fight so I know to jump right into it
and and we write at it uh but uh
Rodriguez has uh Russell up against the
ropes and Russell is trying to fight his
way off the ropes right now so
um Rodriguez is just you know hunting
him at the moment and and Russell's
trying to Stave it off he's not really
moving no head movement no stuff like
that because he's still a little bit
dizzy now he got rocked early I think it
was like round five uh Russell did and
he got rocked by a right hand at the
temple and uh Rodriguez jumped on him
then but see Rodriguez right now he's
just countering
um Russell every time Russell throws uh
a lead right hand uh um well Russell's
the South Park Elite left hand uh he
leans over and he throws a straight
right hand and hits him right on the
temple so you know uh Gary Russell is in
um all the way there he's trying his
best but at the moment right now
Rodriguez is really out boxing him he's
he's fainting he's moving he's uh
slipping and he's throwing the right
hand right he just uh Gary Russell just
tackled him on the floor what's going on
people
all right thanks so much for your takes
my friend thank you brother shout out to
my mans what's going on what's going on
yo did anybody catch the women fighting
today
boy they showed the men how to do it uh
shout out to Clarissa Shields shout out
to Alicia baumgarter they both won their
respective fights and um Alicia uh um
Clarissa
is
Undisputed unified champion in this is a
third weight class oh snap Gary Russell
just threw an overhand right and just
dropped Rodriguez to the floor I don't
think Rodriguez is getting up this is a
fight that Gary Russell was losing and I
don't think Rodriguez is getting up
did he slip or did he get hit hold on
I'm watching the replay
right now
oh
what the hell just happened
what the hell so the rough isn't
counting uh Rodriguez is cut under his
eye
uh
wow wow that was just wow
wow that that I got to see the replay
because I was telling you all about the
women and I wasn't even looking down at
the fight uh
okay hold on
all right so
all right Russell oh there's a head
blunt it was a head bunt it was a
headbunt he threw a right hand and
missed was a head bun and he fell down
all right so okay so let me see
all right they there they're right back
at it again so talking about the women
today the women um you know Clarissa
Shields is probably the greatest uh
woman boxer
to ever lace up a pair of gloves
um
that that was incredible
to to actually see to be honest with you
um she gutted it out she gritted it out
and it was insane
actually insane fantastic stuff I loved
everything about it just three different
weight classes where you know
um
she has become Undisputed
and you can't take nothing away from her
you know she she is very dominant and
she went in she gutted it out over a
heavy hitter uh as an appoint opponent
all right so good
so right now Rodriguez came out and he
dropped Gary Russell and I don't think
Gary Russell's getting up now that was a
punch
his legs is shot
I don't know if the referee is going to
let this continue
oh okay
I don't know if the referee is gonna let
this continue
oh wow this this is this is a wild one
this is an absolute wild one all right
so the round is over
then oh okay so they never reset the
round there's a lot of stuff that's
going on in this Gary Russell fight
right now
and it was one second left in the round
so they was talking to Rodriguez in the
corner Rodriguez comes out the corner
and he hits Gary Russell with overhand
right Gary Russell goes down his legs is
shot he's wobbly and then the bell rings
absolutely nuts pandemonium this is this
is really crazy I mean I can't lie
and this is one of the fights that you
know it's one of those ones that I
wanted to see from my for my personal
but then you know what you got to give a
shout out to Alicia baumgarden uh from
coming out of nowhere and beating Myers
um the fact that she was able to take it
to Myers and in a lot of those exchanges
she gave more than she was uh receiving
she actually uh uh put a good uh string
of um punches together here it is see
okay so that was the first knockdown and
not the not the punch
they got to show the punch they got a
shoulder punch
but uh uh Alicia bumgada you gotta give
her a lot of props this is her first
joint she went over there and she said
she's not giving a rematch she's going
after the last belts because she wants
to become Undisputed and
I don't blame her I mean you know you go
for it uh so
again that's tradition what you sipping
on put it in the chat this is uh
Sunny V
Sunny V
don't let the kids get it
all right so out of the two fights today
I wanted to pick this fight uh Deontay
Wilder coming back uh fighting helenius
because I thought uh this was a little
bit more relevant for the heavyweight
division right and then you have Devin
Haney versus cambosa's part two where
until today Devin Haney looked good but
then I seen him look weight dream at the
weigh-in
I don't know what the hell he did uh
from last night or two days ago until
the actual weigh-in
but uh he looked hella weight drained
and he didn't look great so um I don't
know man
um
that that one fight right there that
kind of makes me nervous and I'm gonna
see it later but I thought you know uh
Deontay Wilder coming back in and him
being uh 214 pounds coming in this fight
he hasn't made 214 since uh 2018.
and uh I don't know if that's gonna
affect them is he going to move faster a
little bit better
along the ropes uh I I don't I don't
know
so uh hopefully uh Deontay actually is
able to you know shoot that right hand
we can see if he still has something
left is he going to fight Joshua later I
don't want to see him fight Fury again
uh maybe usick uh you know um Big Baby
Davis somebody actually to give this guy
a test uh is he still the the second
best heavyweight in the world
we know he's the the most hardest
hitting heavyweight to being a
heavyweight division let me see
cranberry and Hennessy on Deck Isaac
that's what's up my man Isaac for sure
cranberry and Hennessy that'll end the
night for a lot of people
all right so this round right has taken
way longer than it's supposed to it's
round nine okay so I think the fight is
over and I think they're going to the
score cards
okay so I think they're going to
scorecards I think the fight is over
after round nine I think this guy uh
couldn't continue uh Rodriguez and
I I don't know
I mean I can't call it I I wouldn't have
stopped the fight
but I guess uh they said uh Rodriguez
couldn't continue because Rodriguez head
was spinning I guess
and he was up on the card so maybe they
felt that you know they take they win
and just go home with it
I don't know I I don't think that's you
know that's cool but
tell me what y'all think about Deontay
what what do you expect from him tonight
do you do you think he's gonna come in
hungry do you think he's gonna come in
trying to box
uh I hope I hope I hope
because he could have over trained in in
um
camp
trying to overcompensate for those
losses to Fury
then he's fighting you know helenius and
and Helena is Rob helenius remember that
used to be a sparring partner
so you have your sparring partner coming
in and
technically you're supposed to beat him
you're supposed to knock this dude out
right you're supposed to you know um
dispatch him because he's supposed to be
his foreign part in your Chief's Farm
partner
but uh helenius has a good right hand
and if uh he's taking your best in
sparring
who who's who's to say that he doesn't
come out and
show you a different wrinkle
maybe maybe
he feels that uh he has something to
prove I don't know there's a lot of
things going into the fight a lot of
question marks going into uh does
Deontay Wilder still have it and I guess
that's why I picked this fight over
the George camposis uh Devin Haney fight
for Devin Haney
cam Bose's fight you know
being at uh you know Haney is the
Whatchamacallit is the lead man now so
I don't know man it's this is this is
one for the agents this is one to see
and you know I said the same thing you
know
um with the with the shields fight
because I wanted to see if Shields can
um
bring it
and she definitely did she definitely
gave 110 so you know shout out to her
and I know she's watching Mccalla I know
she's very happy with
her win and and so is Alicia baumgarden
if y'all didn't get a chance to see it
you know at the end of this you know go
to top rank go check out the highlights
go see this is the first time to be
honest with you that I've seen uh three
separate uh promotional events
on the same night or the same day and it
was like a pick and choose type of thing
pick these fights or
or don't and then you have a UFC fight
tonight as well so it's a lot man it's a
lot
yo I I Isaac
he needs to make it a quick uh fight
tonight he needs to show that he's still
a dominant presence that's still at
dominant Force because there's a lot of
question marks since
um
the the the fury fights right it's a
it's we we have question marks and we
want to we want to know if these uh
questions are going to be answered you
know uh did he start training legs now
is Deontay doing squats is he doing road
work
it's these questions that we need
answers to you know um
Deontay over the years is notorious for
not doing road work so his stamina
suffers as a result
you know so hopefully I mean guys cut up
guys rip guys strong but
does he have the endurance
and hopefully in this Camp that's
exactly what they worked on they worked
on that endurance with him because we
know he has a chin we know he has a
punch
um he's not the greatest looking boxer
as far as form and discipline goes no so
we have to accept that already right
does he have the bounce back does he
have the grit is he doing the full
payday you know is these questions that
we're we're asking ourselves going
forward and what we expect from him I
really do want to see him fight Joshua
at least you know I I don't care
too much for Joshua versus
um
Fury
in my opinion I already know what's
gonna happen in that fight furry gonna
beat the brakes off of him right so
that's that's not what I what I want to
say I would like to see Fury versus USIC
have Fury versus you usik have
um
you say uh
Ortiz versus uh Wilder after this or or
not not King Kong Ortiz
um Louis Ortiz uh or or
have
um Wilder versus uh this guy
um Joshua
I think I think that works I I want to
see that I I want to see
Wilder because I think Wilder with a lot
of different matchups in the heavyweight
division works well the same thing I
feel the same thing about uh Joshua but
I think the Zone has held on to Joshua
so long that they made him stale over
there right when he when when he was
coming over here and fighting these
other guys he had you know he lost so
you want to expand these heavyweights
have these heavyweights fight different
heavyweights all across the board uh let
Fury fight using let those guys fight it
out let them make a unified Champion I
think that needs to be done right
because Fury needs to have those
challenges usick is that challenge for
him and let these two finally fight it
out I I don't want it to become Riddick
bold versus Linux Lewis the fight that
we never had let Deonte and Joshua get
it on let's see exactly what they got
maybe they can get two or three fights
out of the deal I think they can command
big money
what's going on black addict
you know um
I I really just I want to see that
the biggest thing is who the hell does
Clarissa Shields fight next
[ __ ] Shields has cleaned out every
division she's been in
who the hell is gonna give her a
challenge
sure she
she's so dominant that she had to go to
a sport that's not even her sport to get
a challenge
so
who do we put her up in there with you
know you can't say bumgarten bum
Gardener is very exciting but she's just
still green right now to be honest with
you
might be a thing it might be after
Elicia you know unifies then they fight
each other
she ain't fighting me
let me see
he said oh man no more Hennessy you
heard what it did today's County yo
she ain't fighting me I ain't fighting
that lady that lady Rough and Tumble Bee
she got she got a knuckle game it's
incredible
all right so you got Deontay right now
in the back
um
he has a suit on he didn't even get
warmed up yet uh
so you know it's 10 o'clock already so
what we figured anyway
is the next fight uh
is going to be to fight the setup so
what we have is Caleb plant
versus Andre Harrell
and uh
that that that's that's that's a good
one
we haven't seen Caleb since what he lost
to Canelo
so well I haven't
let me see
she might have to fight you King she
down here with me in the D pause
she down here with you in a d pause
to shut you down sir
you we you wavy
um
I don't know man deontay's looking he
doesn't he looks like it's so but he
doesn't look like himself and I guess
that's that's us in human nature right
we want to see we want to try to figure
out if we can get a a tip to see if
something's off about somebody
so we can you know call of Vegas and hit
those bet nods right uh I I don't think
Anthony uh is looking right uh I put 20
on the opponent
I don't know man
Deontay right now
they should have been loosening up in
the background
but
I'm not gonna pass judgment you can get
loose within an hour so I I don't know
but that this fight you should only have
like one or two fights right before the
main so I don't know exactly what's
going to happen right now
my brother
peace for show
um
I don't know man I don't know I look I
look as I saw changes in Deontay with
the last fight with Fury right and
he was a little bit more docile
right when when a person is an
aggressive
um force and you and you feel
the aggressiveness right so you got Andy
Ruiz yeah I said Ortiz yeah Andy Ruiz
um
Frank Sanchez that's that's pretty good
joy joy so get out of here all right so
Andy Ruiz uh I would say I would love to
see him versus Deontay Wilder right so
in in the scale they're showing a
heavyweight landscape Frank Frank Frank
Frank Chad Sanchez he's he's decent but
um
he's not proven right excuse me I would
have Frank Sanchez versus uh Luis Ortiz
right instead of Andy Williams versus
Louis Ortiz but that was a good fight
within itself
that I felt that Andy won that fight off
of just the knockdowns if there's no
knockdowns in that fight Andy doesn't
win that fight because I think Ortiz
boxes him well but you know he said it
was a couple of hits
and boom
so
I don't know man
um
the landscape looks pretty good but it's
about the promoters getting the fighters
to fight and we're not seeing that we're
not seeing exactly what we want to see
we want these promoters to allow these
guys to actually fight across the boards
because we we thought at this time
we would have been getting uh what is
that um
Crawford versus Spence right and we
figured it would be in October or
November 19th and we haven't still
gotten word on this
at all and the word on it is it might
happen next year
because I mean you can announce it this
week and it'll be ready for December
you say uh the second half of December
somewhere like around
the second weekend before Christmas or
the weekend before Christmas that can
work
or or or or you can have it on the
Christmas weekend which but I I don't
think that's a popular weekend I've
never seen fights on the Christmas
weekend so I don't know man
let me see
yes
thank you thank you uh Marshall with
I think um tonight I picked a wild about
uh stoppage
um
I say by the fifth round
I think it should go five rounds
if it goes anything longer than that do
we look into it
do we see anything out of that I don't
think so I don't think that you know we
see
um
we if if it goes seven rounds uh is he a
scrub
got a whatchamacallit
I gotta have moderators
it's just me in here so I gotta remove
them myself
it's ridiculous
to apologize I wasn't important enough
to be getting spam but all of a sudden
now I guess I'm important enough to be
getting spammed
so
uh-huh
all right gotta put the last block in
all right so we got Frank Sanchez
oh Carlos Negron are they fighting today
okay so I didn't know that Frank Sanchez
was fighting tonight and he's fighting
Carlos Negron now that's a damn good
fight to have on the card I thought the
next fight was cool hands versus uh
Darrell
oh okay
this this is a pretty decent fight
I really man please I would have started
this stream at 10 30 then oh my God
wow oh man Dragon heart yobi that's my
brother man peace blessings peace love
life my my guy man
y'all don't if y'all don't follow him
following them follow them please you
know nothing but positivity always a
fantastic dude in the community
and I truly respect all 32 people that
shows up that's uh talking boxing with
us let's talk some boxing
what you're sipping on I don't care if
you're sipping on a little bit of this
shiny hey
I'm not gonna say your name no more
because you're not giving me a sponsor a
little bit of bottled water
[Laughter]
yeah man family's good everybody's good
my son is upstairs he he saw me playing
scoring I asked him if he was going to
play scoring he said nope not gonna do
that Daddy
so I don't know right now he's probably
playing uh
I don't know something something
probably some Halo or something I doubt
it
probably on some Pub G all right so
right now we got Frank Sanchez's uh just
stepped inside the ring
I see
I come from the days where even if you
didn't have to make weight these heavy
weights were in shape a lot of our
heavyweights are just big dudes right
big dudes that hit the bag hit the mitts
Spar a little bit has a little bit of
success
and people put them in there
um
I want to see these dudes a little bit
more cut up man Mike Tyson in his prime
was a rip rip little monster man and you
had Evander Holyfield rip monsters man
these rip monsters yeah Lennox Lewis
always looking ready to fight man
so
I don't know man Muhammad Ali
a physical specimen
you know um Joe Frazier a straight
Savage George Foreman back in the days
not hamburger George
George Foreman back in the days
ridiculous
yo I'ma tell you
yeah no Haney camposis I was gonna do
Haney camposis uh
and I I did I had to pick I had to pick
today
you know either you're gonna pick the
the The Haney fight or you're gonna pick
the the Wilder fight
let me let me see if uh
Haney's still on the undercard right now
I can tell you right now
if they still on on the car because if
they're not on on the card and they're
at the main event
then I'll
probably uh
run it up with them nope
nope
that's the undercard man they on the
undercard
and in no the undercard is completely
bogus man they don't have a good
undercard the undercard is really trash
to be honest with you I didn't see
anything fantastic on that undercar I
thought the strongest card of the night
was the Deontay Wilder card especially
because they have Caleb plant coming
back
um and I thought that was the bright
spot
to be honest with you I didn't even know
Frank Sanchez was on this undercard and
he's one to watch I love how he moves in
the ring
um he has a decent chin decent right
hand uh decent Jab
very very very good fight it's somebody
to watch in the heavyweight division
he might give you
um
he might give you something special uh
you know down the road because he is a
very decent boxer like right now he's
he's showing a powerful jab as he's
stepping in on uh Negron so you know
they're in the center of the ring and
he's jabbing the groan you know to the
chest and he throws overhand right to
try to catch on the ground so he's he's
walking the groaning left hook right
hand uh from Sanchez coming in and he
goes right back to the center to the
ring
and the grown Jabs to the stomach and
you know Sanchez deflects throws
overhand right
and they right back at it again
geez
really ESPN y'all really coming for me
today ESPN really
why am I so important today ESPN
I'm not that important
I'm just a little old God and like
talking Sports
really ain't that serious
yeah it's yo I got no hate on on the on
the fight I really like how Devin Haney
was um
was looking before the wind but Devin
Haney got to the weigh-in and he's he
looked like a zombie
see and and if you're watching that and
you're not watching these heavily see
that undercard doesn't look good but if
you're not watching these heavyweights
right now these heavyweights you know
Sanchez looks good Sanchez in the grown
is throwing some heavy leather right
here
I would honestly tell you to you know
shift over and and get a taste of this
right here pause
the better undercard now better main
card the better main card is cambosis
versus Haney right but then you got to
see the interest out of those two is
either one of those two gonna get a
knockout right and you figure Deontay
Wilder versus helenius
while to get that knockout right oh
Hellen needs to get that knock out one
of the two but you but you figure those
big boys is gonna put together something
excuse me
that's not going to look like a waltz
it's not going to look like a dance uh
for 12 rounds right so we figure
Haney [ __ ] out box kombosis again
because I don't think tombosis has
anything
to stop Devin Haney nothing at all
let me see what you got here
move that down
Jesus Christ they're back again
mm-hmm
yeah yeah those boxing shoes is very
important
Jesus did did they show back up again
Andy showed you the box the gym is not
necessary
all right so we got um
helenia is right here right now and he's
he's gloving up you see this is this is
the difference this is what I'm trying
to talk about
uh hellenius is is
he's gloving up right now right
he's warming up when we saw Deontay
Wilder
he he was just sitting there right he
just got in he had his suit his tuxedo
suit on
I don't know
I don't know I I tell you this
if if helenius beats him
wrap them up pack them up throw them
away that's it
am I watching the Anderson fight
I am a wrestling fan
with tank Garcia right you you tell me
where's tank Garcia
Garcia does more talking than actual
fighting so
when are we gonna see uh Garcia in in a
fight
of the magnitude of his mouth
right uh
beautiful Talent
when are you gonna fight
that's the huge question we got tank
there tank just for it so he said tank
was looking for a fall a fight in the
fall
and I think uh Canelo stole his date uh
with that fight so
you know Jesus Christ
what is going on they are hitting me up
today I think I'm gonna start
getting moderators
for these
box that's popping up in here this has
never happened usually they leave me
alone man what the hell is it an iron
Lords thing
I'm like oh let's attack him because
he's a lord what the hell is this about
wildest thing ever my wildest thing ever
I'm not even that important it's only a
beautiful 40 people watching come on man
black addict what you saying uh to be
honest King you do well but I feel like
you're missing a co-host to bounce off
to make the show feel like better in my
opinion though yeah it's probably true
do you have oh do you thinking of having
your own podcasts out or what you're
doing tomorrow I saw Smackdown
um
attic and I was doing uh uh um a show
and you know that stuff would be nice
you know so I get a chance to bounce off
my co-host there
um as far as boxing goes you know who
really wants to be up with me on a
Saturday night uh bouncing off uh um
combat talk it was going to be me and
Jay Fonzarelli uh and you know we
working we was talking about things and
stuff like that uh but we had to include
UFC and I know nothing about UFC but I'm
willing to learn at all times you know
but again so
who I'm gonna bounce it off of man I
just want to hang out I'm going to talk
box and I'm going to watch the fights
and I'd rather watch the fights and talk
with with a lot of people that's out
there that's let's say right now you
bought
and I get a chance to talk to you about
it right
yeah lemon is perfect for this but
Saturday night getting lemon up to watch
a fight after he did his show earlier
people think that this this stuff is
easy this stuff is not easy you know he
did a what a two-hour show earlier today
so to get lemon to do you know get up
and come out tonight and do it again
that's crazy what's up fuzzy
let me see
off topic but I can't wait yeah black
items this Friday
they didn't promote or had a bad
reporting of this fight did here at the
Friday
um now they they they were um
promoting the fight
but again they felt that Deontay
Wilder's name is large enough to carry I
don't think in this digital era right
now these dudes know how to promote
fights you know you got dudes that you
like let's say Crawford and Spence right
let's just take those guys and I hate
talking about those guys at nauseam
right now especially when they don't
gotta fight for us to talk about right
but you got these two individuals that
can actually promote a fight and go out
and have that fight reach a pitch that
everybody wants to see it
this right here you got to say these two
individuals didn't promote to their
fullest they thought Deontay name would
carry the banner and again this weekend
you had three fights three fight cards
from three different promoters that
drowned each other out you have the
Devin Haney camposif you have uh this
fight uh card itself and then you have
the fight card with the uh with the
women
right with Clarissa Shields
and bomb garden and them
so I don't know man Galveston was good
so oh great Left Hand by um I mean left
hook by uh Frank Sanchez
see these this undercard PBC puts
together some really good undercuts like
if you want to go to a card and if you
want to take your money you want to
spend your money
from top to bottom PVC cards or PVC
cards are the good of the goods right
uh the Zone probably puts together the
worst cars out of the three and then if
you're looking at top ranked top rank is
after that right so
you know these dudes is mixing up pretty
decent I don't want to call this fight
because you know I'm going to definitely
save it for either
um
uh what you call Caleb plant
and Darrell give you a portion of that
and then save it for the main event
because I think the main event is going
to be a a shocking uh delightful fight
but uh Haney and and camposis I don't
know maybe they probably try to squeeze
a third fight out of it I have
absolutely no idea what's the strategy
in in
that weight dream he looks so bad like
Devin Haney did he looked terrible
but uh
I don't know like to to actually
get them in the ring and see what was
what's Haney's hydration process
afterwards is it IV because see as a
heavyweight I didn't have to worry about
being a weight dream because I would
come in and make weight right so
you're talking about these lighter
weights that have a threshold that they
have to hit and uh a weight Banner that
they have to come under
I don't know the the hydration process
is really telling
because I'll let you know if he's going
to be weakened if he's not going to have
the speed
it's it's a lot of things excuse me if
he can't make that weight I don't I
think he should just get out of the
weight division go up fight tank go up
to that division just you know but don't
campaign at a weight that he was looking
like a zombie at that that was the worst
I've seen Devin Haney look at a weigh-in
ever
ever so
maybe it's something that's going to
come out of that maybe cambosis has a
shot tonight let me see
next Halloween okay next Saturday
that's right
okay so weight dream is this right
let's say uh you got to make it to
160 pounds let's Okay so let's say
you're at the the middleweight weight
right middleweight is 160 pounds so
let's say
um two days before that that your
official weigh-in because the whole time
you're balancing your weight let's say
two days before your official weigh-in
you're three pounds over
so what what they would do is
um when I was fighting in uh light
heavyweight Cruiserweight uh that stuff
when I was younger
they would have sauna suits on you they
put me one time inside a car right and
um
it had plastic on the Windows had the
heat on I'm in there sweating had a a a
breathing mask this is this is I didn't
have any money
um had a breathing like uh like an
oxygen mask for like a snorkeling right
you had that here and um a tube outside
the top and I was able to breathe that
way while I was sweating inside had
garbage bags on me this is ridiculous
but to lose the weight
all right so you get down to the weight
that you desire uh you don't eat uh for
two days very little fluids your body
can go into shock some type of weird
shock and if um
what's that uh cyborg Chris cyborg the
girl Chris cyborg she almost died from
uh the dehydration process that she used
to make weight you know cutting weight
is very dangerous so she almost died
from that it's a lot of process there's
a lot of different processes people do
then after you make the weight after you
get on the scale right immediately you
can tell somebody that has had an
extreme weight cut is when immediately
right after they get off to get off the
scale and they weigh in
they'll put a a chew in the mouth now
that true is a protein shoe that they
throw in their mouth and then they'll be
drinking a a liquid now you think that
liquid is
um
like uh water it's not more than likely
it's Pedialyte you know that's what you
give the babies right so when they're
dehydrated or when they have diarrhea or
something like that so they would drink
the pedia like in the Pedialyte will
rehydrate them all the way right back
but also then they would go upstairs and
you know get in a room and they'll put
them on an IV uh and and just build
their body up that way for a couple
hours and then it would eat a good meal
or whatever to get some substance in
their stomach after they uh rehydrated
their body back with the fluids but
they're basically drained all the way
down with their body from the fluids and
uh that's what goes on
um sometimes in these divisions where
you have to make weight it sucks really
bad it's very dangerous for the fighter
and sometimes you know it can end in in
some type of fatality because the
fighter gets inside the ring
they're not as sharp they don't have as
much power
um their bearings is not all the way
there because you put your body through
these extreme conditions and then you
get to the space where you're supposed
to fight and you don't have everything
there so I Devin Haney
um if if I'm a betting guy and I was
looking for a cue to to even bet on
camposis right
that would have been my cue that's why I
always tell you guys I don't ever say
um who's going to win or what's going to
happen until after I see the day of the
weigh-in after I see what the the
fighter looks like because when I see
what the fighter looks like from my two
eyes and what they weigh in usually you
can get a measure on how the camp went
on the scale like what was the weight
what what um
what did they come in like tonight with
Deontay Wilde they come in at 2 14. he
hasn't made 214 since 2018 right that
that weight tells me a couple of things
that he could have either over trained
while he was in um camp or
or
he has a nutritionist that has kept his
body at this level
now
from what I know from the camp
he sparred a lot he hit the mitts a lot
he hit the bag a lot upwards of six to
seven hundred rounds that's unheard of
at a person his age so that means that
he could have over trained for this
fight could he have tired arms could he
have tired legs could he have achy
joints a lot of things can happen
mentally you could be worn out you could
have left your days inside the gym so
again
um you look at all these things going
into a fight now I don't know like from
a betting standpoint how does that work
in Vegas or something like that but they
I'm pretty sure that they take notes so
I don't know going into this fight um
I know he's uh he's the the what you may
call it the betting um the bed and
favorite and helania says the underdog
so
I don't know does it hurt to put like uh
20 on Helens
you know because let's say right now he
over trained
and he gets in that ring he doesn't look
like himself looks slow looks lethargic
it loses
highly possible
yeah you can come back the next day none
of that stuff is safe
so
like let's say tonight Devin Haney comes
in for this fight 10 to 15 pounds
heavier and you know and a lot of dudes
like to say um
whatchamacallit
Fozzie was good
um a lot of dudes like to say that uh uh
Spence
is a weight bully they call them weight
bullies
that they they these dudes getting in
there to say tank does it
um
said Ryan Garcia was trying to do it but
he's not disciplined enough to do it
so
a lot of times these individuals use the
weight game Oscar was Notorious for
using that weight
to get people at a disadvantage and then
he showed that information to
um Canelo and Canelo uses that
information to the best of his ability
a lot of times he has these guys come
down and they're weight drain and then
they have rehydration Clauses too so the
rehydration Clause is you can't come in
weighing a certain amount of weight
after you wait in let's say a dude the
day before weighed in 160 right
the rehydration Clause is you can't come
in 15 to 20 pounds heavier
the next day
and if you do you're penalize
Canelo and Oscar learns that very well
so
that's why Canelo thought he was going
to have bevel right where he wanted him
um because Bibble wasn't able to
rehydrate all the way up to his normal
like his Bible will come in a slight
heavyweight right there's 175. uh bevel
will come in anywhere as 190 uh 195.
bevel couldn't come over I think it was
like 180 something like that and Canelo
came in at uh
167 I believe or 168 something like that
he didn't do the whole 175. so but they
was making sure that Bible didn't come
in all the way too heavy
devil didn't care devil came in his way
and he actually did exactly what he was
supposed to do with uh somebody coming
up to his weight class defending his
belts
he said Canelo Mexican meat
yeah this might be a Devin Haney's last
fight at 1 35 the way he looked if
everyone was manipulating the way class
they all do it the rehi Jason causes or
something BS though ain't he looking
like Sony's acquisition budget way yo
you stupid as hell
Devin Haney look like Sony's acquisition
budget I look anemic he's looking like
baby Skeletor
um
not everybody manipulates the weight
right not everybody you have a lot of
guys there that don't manipulate the
weight you have a lot of guys that fight
at the weight
some people are hugely naive right or
some people just don't want to have to
worry about gambling because all right
you're gambling with your purse
that's all these dudes do they they
it's your purse this is what you're
fighting for you are a prize fighter the
prize is your purse right so you don't
want to gamble with it right so you want
to be on weight whole Camp you want to
take your your boxing and your training
very seriously for the whole year so
you're supposed to
right a lot of dudes don't so a lot of
dudes cut corners and a lot of dudes
look for trickery a lot and that leads
you down a slippery slope because again
if you're feeling lethargic you're going
to take something not to feel the
lethargic you're going to take some uh t
uh HGH you're gonna do something like
some testosterone replacement you know
so or
um something to PD all right
testosterone as you um
as you're fighting like because they
sometimes these dudes use these seeds
and you get Spike and adrenaline as
you're fighting
that's why they take a a a urine sample
after you fight and before you fight
right before you fight take your example
and after you fight to take a urine
sample and they
um they check your urine uh samples
against each other
to stay away from all of that
let's do it clean
train properly
stay on weight
get a nutritionist when you get enough
bread
train
don't drink
stay away from those sugary stuff
make your way
you don't have to worry about that stuff
you don't even have to worry about being
a weight bully you can actually fight in
your weight class and don't have to
manipulate any other weight
right now uh Sanchez is running down on
the ground
and um
they're in the center of the Ring nice
left hook from Sanchez nice right hand
left hook from Sanchez Negron does a
little dig into the body oh a powerful
left hook from uh Sanchez on they were
clinched and he you know stepped out of
the clinch and threw a left hook uh from
the hip
very decent stuff I see these are the
heavyweights that I like to watch to to
fight to be honest with you in the
middle of the Ring
um
what's on the undercard for the Devin
Haley uh Campbell's fight who's watching
that right now how far did they get it
did they get to the the fight before the
main event
what's happening
somebody in the chat let me know
because right now we are two fights away
from the main event
let me see
yo what do you think about the Japanese
official disrespecting Floyd act the
exposition Rising ran by the guys who
ran pride and I've seen things just eat
that pause I think people should weigh
in before the fight apart felt bad
people coming in the middle and into the
next class yeah that's crazy all right
so to act answer the first question
Floyd
um
yeah Anthony Darrell boy looking good
um
them disrespecting Floyd
he's the greatest hour sport has to
offer
all right he she he should be revered
right
um could you imagine us uh taking Matsui
and disrespecting Matsui
um one of their uh their great uh
icons Floyd is our great icon he's he's
a walking treasure right
or walking treasure he still has his
faculties
um
he's doing exhibitions around the world
because he worked hard enough I mean
whatever sacrifices however you feel
about the man whatever sacrifices and
stuff like that he did he he he did that
you know every night that he got into
the ring yeah he got paid tons of money
he promoted himself like crazy he did
what he's supposed to do how do you feel
about the man
there's a level of respect
professional respect
That was supposed to be given to him
to throw his the flowers on the floor
I don't know if it was part of a an act
I don't know if if it was part of a skit
you know they trying to show the hill or
whatever try to rile the crowd up
if it wasn't
and if it was mean-spirited and if it
was doesn't wasn't done ingested it
wasn't done with the explicit knowledge
of Floyd knowing that
I boo I boo you
um
because that's that's
not how we treat our best
you you wouldn't like it if we took your
best and we treated your best that way
right so the same way that your best is
in a foreign country you want them to be
retreated with reverence and respect I I
expect Floyd to go to any any
country and be treated with respective
reverence
because he earned it he earned it with
his Blood Sweat and Tears so I find it
highly disrespectful it it was
definitely disheartening but that shows
you the caliber of the man
Floyd picked up the flowers and
went along with it you know so the
caliber of the man spoke opposed to uh
the disrespect of uh of an individual
who
Floyd's probably never had a crossword
with the dude you know so for him to
even feel that he's justified in doing
something like that to a man who has
earned the respect of a Nation
disgusting disgusting to me so you know
and and he and he and the dude was a
public official
all right so
this is this is the level of hypocrisy
that goes along in the world because had
Floyd done something like that would
have been public outcry but when it's
done to Floyd
and I can say a whole bunch of other
stuff but I'm gonna rise above it right
it's just disheartening to be honest
with you
hard to find we cool man king those are
the yakuzas and they run pride and
something had to have went down
business-wise scene that made me nervous
from for real yo listen
he's in a foreign country
you know what the difference is with the
mob
you know the difference is with the mob
here
you come here back in the days used to
fight in Vegas this then the Third
let's say China sends over their best
the mob ain't gonna let nothing stupid
like that go down
say whatever you want to say
and I guess I'm being biased right
not saying that there's in racism within
that organization
but who look back
who look back that whole nation looked
back in my eyes that whole nation looked
back because of the ignorance of one
individual
because the public outcry wasn't there
for Floyd who was a national Treasurer
he's putting on a damn exhibition
he doesn't have to go there to put on an
exhibition for y'all y'all called
terminated to put on an exhibition y'all
put up the money for him to put up to
the exhibition the exhibition was done
at your request but at your request he
is not treated as as as what she'll ask
for you treated him lesser than so I I
don't respect that you know so I think
that we have enough class here
that we won't allow that to happen to
any nationalist that comes over from any
place else I think we respect them and
treat them with respect here so that's
just me right
I mean I I I I don't I don't have a son
that seen that done here but to see that
done to somebody else especially Floyd
no hell no and I don't give a hell I
don't give a damn what anybody says
about
how they feel about him
he has never done anything wrong to you
you can say you don't like his little
skit and money mate
some people don't like it I don't care
he didn't do anything to me though right
and you gave the flowers to the one guy
give the flowers to Floyd just the same
way but that's why he knocked your boy
out
and he got paid
and he went home on on his jet
and he went to bed in his silk seats so
that doesn't cover up the hurt because
the hurt
goes deep into the man you know it sucks
man we supposed to have different
professionals
um you know just sucks
I love Shields today
I I think listen
I I hope
I hope
it was staged I hope it was staged with
his knowledge and I I you see I will
give them the benefit of the doubt
that's what I would do
I would give them the benefit of the
doubt but
the date the times that we live in you
you think you know
yeah Floyd don't you think Floyd earned
it though to be honest with you you know
Muhammad Ali and George Foreman and a
lot of these dudes used to do
exhibitions when they when their career
was over they do Expeditions and he's
just the latest you know Pacquiao's
doing an exhibition right now with a
with a kickboxer
you know um get your money dudes get
your money
no promoters you the promoter
y'all set up the fights and get your
money because
these promoters
excuse me
made more money off of these Fighters
than these Fighters made in the ring and
you know you know Pacquiao
you know pays out gives a lot of money
out to the homeless and stuff like that
and even though he ran his campaigns and
everything but he was doing stuff for
his country so yeah please let these
guys fight let these [ __ ] guys do
exhibitions why did Jake Paul and these
guys make all this money where they
never you know stood in the ring let
these guys make their money it's time
for them right yeah it's cool
we used to go to the Armory and watch
fights all the time right exhibition
fights and stuff so yeah I think that's
that's a cool thing for them to make
some money they did they deserve it
yo let me tell you something I don't
think I don't think
Shields put a beating on Marshalls
I just believe Shields gave as good as
she got and gave a little bit more
right like she said she dug down deep
and Marshall cracked her with a lot of
good shots man she hit her with a lot of
good shots and you know Clarissa shook
it off she tweet you could tell when
Clarissa spars she spars with men
no knock on the other girls
but
she goes and actively gets sparring from
the best because I heard that she
spoiled with Earl Spence I heard that
she sparred with Andre Ward I've heard
that she sparred with a ton of guys like
the Darrell Brothers
um I I've I've
heard that she actually spars with these
guys and they say that she actually
works she puts in good work so at the
end of that fight after like the sixth
round I saw the bite down that she had
because uh Marshall was hitting her with
some good shots
you know
oh and uh all right so Sanchez just
knocking the ground down with a straight
right hand and the ground slid into the
ropes like he was praying like he was an
altar boy
absolutely something crazy
um this this this one should be over any
second right now saying oh
Sanchez is uh ran in on him and he's uh
throwing heavy shots in the middle of
the ring but Negron is throwing heavy
shots as well but remember from
heavyweight it takes only just one shot
but Sanchez is trying to land that
perfect shot to get him out of there you
got a minute 47 left in the ninth round
Sanchez throws over him right and
um
looking around his uh
throwing a nice jab beautiful left hook
from um Sanchez Negron looks terrible oh
okay this fight is over
he hit it he hit him with a left hook
right hand uh Frank Sanchez did uh
Negron is knocked out in the uh the
ninth round good
that was that was a very decent and I
told y'all Frank Sanchez out of that
group that I saw is a very decent
Fighter
um just give him a little bit more you
say probably two more fights at
heavyweight um some good stiff tests
have him fight either Luis Ortiz and I
think that's a good fight for him oh oh
Andy Ruiz
that's a hell of a fight I don't know
what happened to Big Baby Davis but um
that's that's a hell of a fight all
right so this guy is uh Negron nose is
broke he has a cut on the bridge of his
nose
um fight is over
you know he's heavy swelling across his
face
really good fight really good fight
I'm saying Marshall did didn't even
believe that she won the fight with me
she was reading this this is a fact
Marshall facial decision said it all
yeah Spas with men I'm skeptical maybe
just getting in some work it would be
hard for me to to throw back I probably
wouldn't listen
when
I'm pretty sure when Clarissa spars with
these guys it ain't full out hard
hitting sparring I don't know
but to actually share the ring with a
champion and for them to give you
pointers
that's what I'm talking about to to to
teach you how to dip your shoulder when
a jab is coming in so it can slide those
couple of seconds that it could slide
past and what you're supposed to be
doing in those couple of seconds what
shots you're supposed to be coming with
should you go to the levels you should
you bring it over the top uh or should
you shoot a straight right if those
those those things is invaluable that
another champion can teach another
champion right little subtle things with
your footwork those things can be taught
um and maybe sometimes uh you are a fan
of somebody and for them to say
something to you even though your
coaches is talking to you you probably
pick it up a whole lot easier right so
I'm telling you it showed it showed at
the end of that and and I think it was
like from the sixth round on
it just I started to see the separation
as far as class though and even though
Marshall beat her in in
their images
you can see the separation
as the pro
and I think it was like sixth round on
Clarissa just started doing little
things that was showing that she was a
step up and when it came to the class
acts you know it was a step up she had a
little bit more bumgarden showed me some
stuff that I didn't expect to see from
her I thought that Myers would uh take
bumgardner to to deep Waters and drown
her nah Palm Garden show that she could
swim but I'm going to boy
um that's somebody to see like that's
that's somebody to see she she has this
she has to bounce she she looks like a
season season Pro and she's not and and
you know if he was going off a resume
alone you'd put you to put my hair but
um bumgartner showed um she had
something special she believed in
herself and
she said she ain't giving that lady no
rematch
so she was going she's going for the for
the Gusto she was going for everything
let me see what you what you got for me
dip down what's good yeah yo I'm telling
you she showed a lot in the ring today
against Marshall and when you say a
fighter like Marshall
Marshall's the champion
Marshall is is is is a heavy hidden
woman did you see how big that woman
compared to to a shield
Marshall is a big woman
like she really put in oh man it was
that was something like she's a big
woman and and a long jab straight right
hands and she knows how to dig to the
body
um I'm sorry
this is not the days of when we watch
women boxing and women boxing aren't to
the same standards as men boxing because
I know dudes felt like that in the past
but right now when I watch them fight
my God like the level of skill is here
and what I saw in that car today was a
level of skill of women that was here it
had Head and Shoulders above a lot of
these undercards that we're seeing today
right
um I'm pretty sure that you know Head
and Shoulders over the Devin Haney uh
undercard let me let me let me check
that on the card right now to see if
they even got to uh
the Devin Haney fight itself
because um
that's a possibility right right now let
me see
okay I think they're coming in now
to be honest with you
if if if they do
what I would do is I would skip the
Caleb plant on the PVC and I will go to
Sky Network and I would uh
do the Devin Haney cambosa's main card
and then uh hopefully tequila plant and
uh Darrell fight lasts really long go 12
rounds which I would not which I which
I'm thinking
okay I think they're ready
I think they're ready
so if if they're ready
if they're ready then we're gonna do the
Devin Haney camposa so we're going to
get the power punch here here we're
going to get the power punch guys so if
if they're ready right now because
they're showing Devin Haiti right now if
they if they're going to go do this
fight right now then I'm gonna call this
fight right here and then we're going to
switch over uh right after this fight
because that'll give us enough time uh
to get in the um Deontay Wilder versus
uh helenius fight
as well
I think Deontay is a legitimate um
Whatchamacallit I think Deontay is a
legitimate uh contender
is this a money grab tonight is going to
tell us if it's a money grab right
tonight is going to tell us if um if
this guy is in it for the full haul or
is or is this just something that he's
just pulling he's just pulling some cash
right um tonight is going to show us and
that's our biggest questions
our biggest questions is going to be
answered because you have a sparring
partner excuse me a former sparring
partner
in front of you
I'm not taking anything away from
helenius
um because his last fight that I saw is
when he was fighting
or with the Polish kid uh the the pizza
guy
um that's I think he's like the fighting
pizza guy but um he has a big contingent
in New York City right uh and I think
that's the last time I saw it but that
was a good fight
and they were doing a lot of give and
take so maybe maybe
we see something from there I don't know
West Coast time
although I get the more I wish the main
event started 10 p.m why don't we do
that for real for real
does he still want it right
all right so Jay Primo
here's the deal I'm gonna call
The Haney fight right now right I'm
gonna call it right now
and um
then we're gonna shoot back over there
and get that Wilder though because right
now we got Caleb plant versus uh Darrell
now even though I really want to see
that fight because ah
I like me some Kayla plant paws
um
I think Main Event trumps all right so
main event we call this main event I
call this fight and then we get over
there and I call the second main event
and we make it a beautiful night
and we go home no fuss no must
you know what I like about
um the Handycam bosses fight
the government has evolved
the government the government sanctioned
this the government has everything to do
with this
the government made sure that the
stadium was available the government
made sure all the flight is the fighters
and everything was there the government
um showed reverence to Haney gave him a
plaque gave him some stuff
um this is this is a different like like
you remember what we was talking about
we was talking about the Floyd thing
they they treated uh Devin very well
from from what I saw so far from that
his father's there early and I liked the
last time when his father had got there
like the day of
um
so
yeah they did a lot of things different
they got a chance to correct whatever
mistakes that they made the last time
and they made it even better and this is
a beautiful turnout everybody is there
for George George camposis and and David
Devin Haney they sold out a Arena they
did a beautiful card and it did and the
government has making sure that you have
the best and the brightest singing the
national anthems
um this this is this is what you want to
see from your government you want your
if your government is going to be
involved with your sport then you want
to see the best of your sport that your
best your sport has to offer and and
this is what they're doing very good
stuff
thank you so much man
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you dip down
put a lot of pressure on the boy
oh tomorrow
um we got the links for the pillows
we got the links for the pillows going
up tomorrow so for anybody that wants
those velor pillows um
that's in collaboration with the iron
Lewis podcast those pillows is going up
tomorrow and for the first hundred
people I'm gonna have a cold
uh and those that code is going to give
you 15 off
so um
pressure make diamonds that's right
that's right
all right so tomorrow uh the the pillows
is going to go up we're gonna we're
gonna have the promo in the beginning
and we're going to uh give out the code
uh and from there it's like Off to the
Races the first hundred people gonna
have that uh 15 off and then uh you know
the pillows is gonna ship out I'm
telling you great stocking stuff of
stuff you know great uh great you stuff
you know just to don't Adorn your man
cave to your space you know
like adding uses it for Elbow Room when
this girl tried to get in you know um
sometimes I use it as a blocker put it
on my shoulder keep my girl out when
she's trying to bother me when I'm
gaming
but uh nah it's uh I don't even feel
like sometimes like when I'm sitting in
a chair I put the pillow on and I don't
even feel it so like it fits my elbows
it because like right now my elbows dick
is digging in the corners of the chair
and the Hand rests I don't know you get
used to certain stuff I get used to
stuff quickly and you know I got used to
that pillow very quickly to be honest
with you very very nice stuff let me see
um
the old Natty full body pillow now man
[Laughter]
now I ain't gonna have nobody out there
with a [ __ ] do you know the level of
disrespect that people could do if they
had a full body pillow of me
hell no I would never consent to that
the things that they would do to my
pillow
oh my God and then I got that [ __ ] put
it on Twitter or YouTube
body nope
could you imagine
oh no no I'm not even gonna give nobody
no ideas no that's just not gonna happen
but right now they uh they're showing
the highlights of Devin Haney I mean um
cambosis uh knockouts
looking good
he surprised me that first fight and
they showed George Campbell's is walking
out right now so he's wearing black and
gold iron Lord colors
uh entourage is very small it's just him
his pops and his trainer and his cut man
very small Entourage
all black hoodie leather looks nice
black shoes
black and gold trunks
looks very nice very nice I mean he got
a good Payday the first fight man
got a good payday
shout out to Campbell's this is a long
ring walk Manny God
dear God boy
they had him coming from the parking lot
and they said your judge
now walk it out
all right he's finally made it to the
arena
let me see if they brought
um these guys out on the other card real
quick
man oh man
y'all gonna have me attempting possible
tonight but hopefully I still have all
the energy left to call both all right
so they're both in the ring right now
so
man
I'm definitely gonna have to see that
later
because there's one I wanted to see boy
definitely gonna have to see that fight
later
alright so since we're gonna do this
George camposa's uh Devin Haney fight
right now because the undercard of the
Deontay Wilder and uh helenius fight is
going uh who do you got
why do you got them do you have camposis
do you have Devin Haiti do you have a
knockout do you have a distance what do
you have why do you have it and who do
you have let me know right now in the
chat
because I
it's kind of crazy
it's kind of crazy
but uh if can boasters can do a couple
of things different
and he can get past that Jab
we can see something totally different
king or current UFC Champions more known
by the average person or the current
boxing champions more than any weight
class I'm ready foresee the aftermarket
they have a full body puller for the
Lord's handy hard 412 camboses all right
so
UFC versus boxing I think they're both
to the average person is is in obscurity
right you know you got people walking
around thinking Mike Tyson's still champ
um
I think they both are very piss-poor
when it comes to public mind share
but if you want to talk about males from
25 to 50 years old they will know the
UFC Champions more right
um
you got some people that think Jake Paul
is a champion
so
um I got to be honest with you
um
the Champions now uh you a lot of people
don't know who the Champions are now in
boxing
I will probably say that the edge has to
go to UFC right now we got Devin Haney
uh highlights of him knocking out his
foes and beating his folks so oh
beautiful right hand beautiful right
here
beautiful
and they showing Devin Haney coming out
right now
biggest thing here
is Devin Haney weight drained
that can play a huge role in this fight
yeah you got Jake Paul saying that he
can walk he can beating Mike Tyson but
he didn't sign that contract when Mike
said that that contract over
because Mike said that contract over
I know that for a fact
he ain't signing that fight
hell no
I I would pay Cole Hard Cash
to see that fight Cold Hard Cash
to see Mike Tyson versus Jake Paul
to see him rip his shoulders rip his
head off his shoulders all right so
Devin is here
let me see
Devin looks hydrated
it looks decent
he's young enough that his body
shouldn't take any ill effects
but you don't know that until you push
the body towards to his extremists right
so
I got uh Devin Haney by 12 round
decision
same as the last
and do I see any knockdowns or knockouts
maybe not I don't think Devin hits hard
enough for a knockdown
or knock out
uh maybe uh he's coming into his own
and we do see a little bit more strength
out of him
uh but also
I don't think
um camboces gets in to show his power
because out of the two I think camboses
shoots his shots a little bit sharper
a little bit more um accurately
I think Devin
slaps with his shots uh his jab is very
serious but
his jab is more of a a measuring stick
and more of a guider right so he'll jab
you guide out
bring it back
um so I don't know
this is this this fight is an enigma to
me
I thought it would pretty much go the
same exact way
as the first fight so
really wasn't too keen on it until I saw
the weigh-in so once I saw the weigh-in
I had second thoughts I said man maybe
this fight is uh something you know to
to see and this is Serendipity right now
that is actually happening and we're
actually gonna see it because
um
we got a chance to have a long card in
which this gives us the opportunity and
maybe that card was shorter they put the
the champions in a ring now
when it comes to the wagering is it
usually for Last Resort no
it's not a lot of dudes do that Gamble
and they drain their body down to a
certain way in order to hydrate because
look at look at uh
Devin Haney right now he does not look
as like the zombie from the last horror
film
he looks hydrated
but what's the effects you know what's
the side effects what's the what's the
ill effects he's he's very young so his
body can bounce back very fast
but then you start to ask yourself older
Fighters don't really like to do it or
really can't do it because it really
hurts them so that's why you see people
go up in weight class and stay in those
weight classes later on
but I do believe this is probably Devin
Haney's last fight at this weight class
unless he there's another fight involved
all right so they're in the middle of
the Ring right now there is no ref oh
they got okay
yo
they have an Asian ref
right now
very small guy
trying to break up these two dudes
this is going to be something to see
let's get it let's get it on all right
all right
round one didn't start yet there
in the corner pacing back and forth
cambosis is pacing like a lion all right
Bell Rings camposis comes out South Paul
quickly switches to off the docks and he
steps in with a jab Devin Haney goes
into defensive position cambosis throws
a couple of punches and he switches the
Southpaw switches right back
he switches to South Pole again he
switches right back I guess this is the
thing that he's going to do tonight uh
cambos is to move from side to side
nervous energy he swings wildly with a
left hook and misses he goes to Southpaw
switches right back Devin Haney Jabs him
all right
cam Bose's Jabs a lot of movement he's
jabbing the Devin Haney's stomach steps
in steps out Devin Haney straight jab
turns them moves
there's a clinch referee breaks him up
they're back in the center to the ring
uh cambosis is switching from South Pole
to Orthodox back and forth constantly
all right and Devin Haney jobs camboces
switches to Southpaw lands it straight
right hand to Devin Haney's face they're
up against the ropes referee breaks them
getting back consent to the ring cam
BOCES goes to Southpaw steps back goes
back to off the decks I think Devin
Haney needs to crack him one time when
he switches to uh Southport
he does it again and he switches Devin
Haney measuring stick jab back out
Jabs from Devin Haney
circling they're back in the center to
the ring cambos his Southpaw and he's
doing Southport to Orthodox to gain
distance he cuts distance when he does
that and then freezes Devin Haney
all right so back to Southpaw back to
Orthodox Southport
back in the center of the ring and Devin
Haney throws a straight right hand and a
jab
all right
South Pole Orthodox all right Devin
Haney throws a body shot to cambosa's
there in the clinch overhand right by
Devin Haney to the back of the head of
cambos's camposis complaints to the
referee referee wants them and Haney
pushes him on the chest and they're back
in the center to the ring camboces has a
lot of nervous energy
all right hands is high
Devin Haney throws a short left hook
misses right hand all right cam Bose's
lunges in they're up against the ropes
devonany has them in the headlock
referee breaks both of them up they're
back again in the center to the ring
cambosa switches the South Pole back to
Orthodox Devin Haney Jabs him in the
face
back in the center to the ring
again nervous energy is down Campbell's
this is slowing down all right one two
three from camboses and our overhand
right to Devin Haney left hook to Devin
Haney right hand to Devin Haney uh
misses with a uh
overhand he leans on Devin Haney neck
round is over okay so the things that I
saw right there I saw that cam Bose has
decided that this camp that he wanted to
switch to Southport and he thinks that's
going to stop anything what I'm noticing
is a lot of nervous energy so he
switches from Southport from um
Southport to Orthodox from Southport to
Orthodox now in doing so what he's doing
is he's cutting distance right so he
puts his right foot forward and then he
switches to his left foot that way he
cut distance and he's in Devin Haney's
stomach he's there all right so when you
put the South Pole you put your right
foot forward and then he switches to
your left foot you're there you've cut
distance while he cut distance he wasn't
throwing any shots right there because
he was looking to see exactly what Devin
Haney was going to do he froze Devin he
needed a couple of times right
but I will have to give camboses that
round because cambosis has did a lot of
dirty under work that was there round
two is starting right now so let's get a
chance to see he kind of threw me off
because I didn't expect him to do that
and this is exactly what he did do Devin
Haney comes out with a jab then the
center of the Ring Denver Haney's trying
to take charge trying to make both the
submissive try to take away that his
Southpaw switching uh camposis is
switching to Southport but he's going
back to Orthodox right now he's doing
both and he keeps doing it
Devin Haney Jabs him Kevin Haney throws
overhand right so right now Devin Haney
is taking a position of uh of the master
when it comes right into the ring he
threw a left hand and a right hand over
the top I can't boasts through two
punches to his body Left Right camposa
switches to South four Devin Haney
throws a one two
catches camposis to the side of his head
the right back oh straight right hand
from Devin Haney double jab straight
right hand camposis takes it well Cam
versus is giving nervous energy switches
to Southport they're having Haney Jabs
throws a right hand pushes down on the
back of Campbell's neck as they clinch
referee breaks him up
all right they're back again in the
center of the ring cambosis is moving
bopping his head up and down Devin Haney
throws a right hand camposis throws two
punches to Devin Haney's body they're
clinched referee comes in right now to
break them up
not too much going on right now so you
said right now there's a lot of
posturing uh cambosa switches to South
Park and he leaps in when he goes right
back to Orthodox they're pushing on the
back of devil hanging his neck
get separated by the referee
switches to Southpaw goes back to
Orthodox that is cambos of Devin Haney
tries to Lunge in with a left hook and
misses he lunges again with a left hook
they're clinched they're trying to fight
their way out of the clinch the referee
breaks them up
these two are doing more holding than
they're actually doing fighting all
right
let's get to it come on guys Kevin Haney
back with Jabs
Campbell's nervous energy
Devin Haney back with Jabs stepping back
lunging left hook from Devin Haney
he misses lunging right hand from Devin
Haney he misses and he catches uh
camposis with overhand right
cambosis is switching from Southport off
the docks
Divinity hit him
Campbell's has kind of went down referee
cleans his hands up
it was a slip
Devin Haney throws a half uppercut
um
with his right hand
very very very minimal stuff here
overhand right from Devin Haney
all right we have no indicator on the
side so okay so as I'm watching right
now there's absolutely no indicator of
the round there's no indicator of the
time so I can't tell you that there's 30
seconds left inside the fight because I
actually do not see that it's 30 seconds
left inside the fight right but again
um same thing but uh camposif is less
effective because Devin Haney saw it in
the first round so he was able to make
adjustments the adjustments Devin Haney
did make in that round was he started
throwing more double uh Jabs double Jabs
and throws the right hand over the top
and that was allowing him to freeze
camboces in his tracks with double jab
tap with one tap again then you throw
the overhand right and then you actually
put in some work but Devin uh what Cambo
system was able to do is when he did cut
distance when he did that uh Southpaw
Orthodox Southpaw Orthodox thing when he
did get in close he did dig a couple of
shots to the body of Devin Haney I think
his idea is Devin Haney was weight
drained so what he wants to do is he
wants to see how much he has in the tank
right right now the frustrated too looks
like camposis but again that looks can
be deceiving we don't know exactly
what's going on round three has started
right now
so I give round two to Devin Haney
camposis does switch again right now he
goes from Southport to orthodox
and right back South Port Orthodox and
right back Devin Heaney throws a right
hand over the top uh cambosis doesn't
stay in South Pole for too long
it's just a distance mechanism
and it's just something to give Devin
Haney something to think about
right because Devin Haney doesn't let
him operate in a Southport stance
then breaking him up again
in the center of the Ring
all right Cambo says throws a jab to the
head to the body Devin Haney throws a
jab
and a right hand and misses left hook
from Devin Haney left hook from cambosa
a lot of folks from Devin Haney he
misses that left hook the Campbell
scissors in his ribs holding on them
referee breaks them up they're back in
the center of the Ring Devin Haney goes
to a left to the body and goes straight
to the face with a jab nice dig with the
left hook Campbell just throws a right
hand and left hook over the top
Devin Haney double jab right hand
freezes camposis and the referee is
going to break them up right now because
there's a clinch in the center of the
Ring
much different fight from the first
fight
Devin Haney looks a little bit confused
but he's getting his bearings throwing
his jab right hand to cambosa's core
cambos is with a left hook right now
they've been uh broken up by the referee
yeah cambos is from behind the head in
the clinch
Devin Haney did Devon Hades back to the
jab cambosis is coming in
Devin Haney is punching camposis in his
back
broken up by the ref
pretty decent stuff right now I can't
lie um
but again a lot of clinching a lot of
clinching Campbell's has switched to
Southport stays there and he gets nailed
by a right hand from Devin Haney I don't
think he should go to South Pole again
that right hand was crazy Devin Haney
has caught camboses with his right hand
left hook uh straight Jab
and again cambosis has stopped the
nervous movement his head is frozen
Devin Haney threw two overhand rights we
might get a knockout in this round Devin
Haney throws a lot for cambosis is
digging to the body Devin Haney throws a
left hook oh my God that right hand over
the top from Devin Haney Devin Haney is
looking at him cambos has switched to
Southpaw and he comes in he grabs Devin
Haney and the round is over that was
what I was looking for Devin Haney
digging those right hands to the side of
cambos's head and camboses took him like
a champ but I'ma tell you that last
right hand wobble camposis that's a big
round for Devin Haney and I give Devin
Haney that round because that round was
definitely Devin Haney's Devin Haney
took exactly what camposis gave him I
told you if he stays in that Southport
stance with two long cam bosses does he
will get hit with a right hand and that
right hand came in like clockwork right
on time always on time and definitely
shook his world boom left hook to the
face Campbell his misses Devin Haney
throws that right hand show that right
hand digs him to the body cam bosus
catches him with a left hook beautiful
stuff that stuff was great I'm watching
The Slow Mo right now beautiful stuff
Hollywood rules two dollar super chat
with sub King King what's up bro just
showing support thank you my brother
thank you I appreciate it 100 first
Super Chat of the day I'm gonna get a
little bell so I can ring it for
everybody that throws a super chat in
I'm gonna get a little belt that's gonna
happen all right here we go round four
uh cambosis switched again I I would
advise him not to he throws a left hook
right hand to Devin Haney's body he goes
right to South Pole again and he
switches back out
I gotta watch the first fight I don't
believe he did this switching like he's
doing right now
all right scambosis looks a little bit
of he has cobwebs in his head right now
and he's standing in the center of the
ring with Devin Haney he's hitting Devin
Haiti to the body referee separates the
two because they were in the clinch
all right cambosis tries to Lunge him
with a left hook and he throws a right
hand but he misses both miserably Devin
Haney's back to the jab and his jab is
right there while his right hand sits
straight clear to his face jab from
Devin Haney
right hand from Devin Haney
jab from Devin Haney
can both his switch and he goes right
back
Devin Haney seems like he's taking more
control and he's throwing the right hand
over the top these right hands are
coming more Fast and Furious
good job from Devin Haney camposis
lunges in with a left hook to the body
and he goes to Southport and he stands
in the Southport stance right there
Devin Haney knocks him out of the South
Pole stands cambosis is back to normal
oh double right hand I mean double jab
right hand from Devin Haney catches
camposis flush on the side of the air
they're clinching right now Devin Haney
seems to be manhandling him but cambosis
is using his head
pause figuratively and literally
oh double left hook from Cambo system to
a right hand
beautiful stuff
switches to uh Southpaw and Russia's
Devin Haney up against the ropes
cambosis does
nervous energy from camposis again he's
standing right in front of him oh a lot
of folks from Devin Haney in close
nice jab as he walks out
Devin Haney back to the jab beautiful
stuff
all right finally
top rank puts up uh a chart we have 27
seconds left in this round Devin Haney's
back to his jab cambosis has slowed down
considerably since the first three
rounds I guess it was those overhand
rights that rung his belly got his legs
a little bit stiff a little Jello like
left hook from camposis catches Devin
Haney as he leans in
Devin Haney was going back he grabs
Cambo says he looks over at his corner
to tell his Corner that he's okay
think that left foot was pretty good
from that uh from Campbell's round is
over
okay Asante what's good what's going on
that's what I'm talking about people's
just showing up we got 43 people here 49
likes love that love that can't complain
so far this fight has a different
complexion than the last fight and um
both Fighters wouldn't have made
adjustments in a camp uh will those
adjustments lead to victory camboces has
seemed to put
um a wrinkle in his game uh to show
Devin Haney something a little bit
different
right and he's doing a lot to get inside
beautiful stuff by cam Joseph she's a
lot of faint a lot of work to get inside
to give Devin Haney more things to think
about than just moving in without his
head moving from side to side Devin
Haney's back and they're back in the
center to the ring this is round number
five
and let's see exactly what they both
have to offer
then back to a jab in the center of the
ring that is Devin Haney camboces is not
switching he's standing there he's
moving from side to side in the Orthodox
stance
and Devin Haney is shooting the right
hand he threw a nice one too and he
threw a nice overhand right nice Jab
Devin Haney is holding this posture
throwing his jab now his jab is working
more cambosa's tries are overhand right
Devin Haney slips
cambosis is giving him more
angles around he's circling Devon Haney
and Devin Haney Jabs them Campbell since
goes to Southpaw then switches right
back and throws the left hook catches
Devin Amy Devin Haney catches him back
there in the clinch right now the
referee is going to break him up
right back at it one more time here we
go
you know I love the I love the spark of
camposis because you see him thinking
you see him thinking a lot but Devin
Haney just threw two uppercuts and one
landed
when uh cambos is Switched and he rushed
in
is doing the most that he possibly can
with the shorter arms
and the left uh athleticism oh left hook
from uh Devin Haney right hand from
Devin Haney nice jab from Devin Haney
camposis comes in he barrows in he
attacks Devin Haney up against the ropes
the referee breaks him up because they
roll into a clinch
cambosis is slowing down ever so
slightly
Devin Haney's back to his jab a jab is a
staple
we got a minute left in this round not
so much switching from South Pole to
Orthodox from camposis oh right hand
from Devin Haney
on the lunge end from camboces
they're right back in the center of the
Ring
nice Jabs from Devin Haney
he's maintaining distance now cambosis
is trying to get around him but he's not
switching to Southpaw anymore right hand
from Devin Haney
left hook from Devin Haney Campos is
Miss wildly with a left hook right hand
all right they're breaking him up 23
seconds left in the round
left hook from Devin Haney camboces and
Swings with a left hook Mrs wildly he
cut the distance rushed up against ropes
to grab Devin Haney into a clinch
and the round should be coming to a
close
round over
um
more work from Devin Haney very slight
work but I saw cambos is doing less of
the South Pole Orthodox South Pole
Orthodox ring cutting off uh tactic that
he was doing in the first four rounds
uh Devin Haney looks no worse for where
they put an ice on his face
merely precautionary because he has no
marks on his face whatsoever he's
drinking water and he's talking to his
father in the corner what he needs to do
is establish a jab what I would tell uh
George camposis to do instead of exactly
um trying to slip the jab Perry the jab
take the jab Perry the jab and work off
the Parry instead I think that works
more effectively when you're working
with somebody has a constant jab because
if you slip what they want you to do is
slip into a position right don't let
them have you slip into a position Perry
the jab so you can step in with the
Perry as soon as you parry all of us
video game players know the moment you
parry you open that's exactly what he
should be doing all right so they back
into the round round number six cambosis
is uh moving his jab up and down wow
Devin Haney throws a right hand he
misses and he throws a left foot
camposis throws a left hook as well
catches Devin Haney partially Devin
Haney missed his left hook cambos has
switched to Southpaw but he switches
right back to Orthodox which is a
softball right back to Orthodox he's in
the corner Devin Haney's back to his jab
Devin Haney is stalking him he's taking
the the lead again in this round
good job straight off the side of the
face of cambosis
oh straight right hand so he did a one
two instead of a double up he did a
one-twoy cambos is flush see and a left
hook if Devin Haney had any ounce of
superior power he would have knocked
Campbell's out already Campbell's to
switch to Southport since the cut
distance Devin Haney sticks his jab out
to form uh Campbell's movement put him
right back into form
Osa jumps back in
referee is going to break them up again
another clinch
so one thing I don't like about this
fight so many clinches
smooth jab from Devin Haney right hand
from Devin Haney
nice jab from Devin Haney
Campos is moving his hand up and down
trying to distract Devin Haney
he moves to South Point he moves back to
Orthodox Southport Orthodox oh left hook
from camboces
separated
from the referee
again back into the center of the Ring
oh right hand left hook from Devin Haney
camposis moves in but he's not throwing
any punches Devon and he catches them
with a right hand freezing him for a
second cambosis is moving him but he's
not throwing any shots he's just moving
left and right Devin Haney throws a
right hand over the top he tries to
catch him with a left hook another right
hand from Devin Haney uh he throws a 1-2
uh straight beautiful jab from Devin
Haney
then a clinch they're breaking them up
Devin Haney is taking more control as we
uh go longer in the fight there's a
possibility of a knockout
off on Devin Haney's part because George
is slowing down at such a pace that um
it's a high possibility that a knockout
is eminent
if he keeps catching them flush with
those right hands
Okay so
right now Devin Haney is at the posture
where his jab is at his hip and he's
bringing it up so it's an up jab that
George can't see
it allows for stuff like uh the uppercut
that Devin Haney just threw to get
inside round is over
so what we saw in that round was more
slowing down from cambosis and Devin
Haney starting to establish his jab more
so you know when Devin Haney's in a
comfortable position his jab comes from
his hip so he likes to throw a up jab so
when his jab comes up you can't see it
coming up and he flicks it to a point
where you don't know if it's another
shot coming in right so the jab comes up
what he did was he threw the up jab a
couple of times and he slipped in a
right uppercut to the body of George
cambosa that can be devastating because
you didn't see the punch coming now if
you hit him in the sternum he could have
dropped him but he didn't what he did
was he hit him probably in the chest
area uh probably around the nipple and
you know George took the shot noticed it
George is slowing down
I would say stop wasting movement and
start worrying about the defensive
discipline on coming in the jab is
Haney's key it can also be his downfall
if you actually time it properly
all right so you have cambos is right
back in the center to the ring uh with
Devin Haney does minor switching
has good foot movement camposis does
but he doesn't use his foot movement to
get inside to deliver the perfect shot
he uses his foot movement to distract
Haney
switches to South Pole makes a
difference but misses
you got to start aiming for the body and
not for the head on Devin Heaney
everybody gets caught up with Devin
Haney not having a chin
Devin Haney throws an overhand right
misses miserably cambosis is in his
section but throws no shots
nice jab from camposis
Devin Haney steps over
he misses
all right so Devin Haney is doing a lot
of fainting he hasn't thrown any shots
really this round very minimal stuff
good job from Devin Haney
good overhand right from Devin Haney
camposis is now worrying about the
overhand right Devin Haney doubled up
with a left hook
and tried to throw a right hand uppercut
didn't land
jab from Devin uh from cambosis that's
pretty decent
nice Jabs from camposis
switches as soon as he switched Devin
Haney shoots the right hand freezes him
every time cambosa switches right now
Devin he throws a right hand he's been
trained to throw the right hand soon as
cambosa switch right hand from Devin
Haney oh my God that was a thing of
beauty it was no jab so right now he is
just pot shouting him with the right
hand another right hand from Devin Haney
Devin Haney is throwing right hands and
he's stepping over to the side right now
so he's walking uh camboses down he's
stuttered stepping jabbits to his body
right hand is to the side right hand is
over the top Devin Haney is now actually
doing a flex this is ridiculous folks
right now he has an open guard he's
inviting cam Boces in but camboses can't
do anything to cut distance Devin Haney
throws a right hand camposis punches
David Haney to the body all right Cambo
says cut distance Devin hey throws a one
two and grabs him for a clinch
referee breaks them up right now Devin
Haney's right back to his posture all
right sent to the ring they right back
into a clinch tap tap tap 24 seconds
left in the round
number seven that is
Devin Haney goes right back to his
posture overhand right catches camposis
Flex
cambosis Cuts distance Devin Haney hits
him with a left hook to get him away
beautiful jab right hand from uh
dominating oh left hook from Cambo I'm
from Devin Haney caught him at the end
of the round a beautiful shot fantastic
shot from Devin Haney I'm not gonna lie
Devin Haney is in much control more so
controlled than he was in the first
fight this fight shows that he learned
he downloaded and processed the
information and he's given exactly what
he processed he worked on a lot of stuff
in Camp and I think he feels a lot more
comfortable right now let me see what
y'all say just shared the stream out
thank you so much dragon
all right nice all right I need a color
content sign me up what's going on a lot
of holding for sure that's right that
was right that was a good one cam bosses
looked beat up he does look beat up he
looks tired he looks I think he wasted a
lot of energy early on moving his feet
back and forth right and if he cut the
distance once you cut the distance you
have to work I thought cam bosses cut
the distance but he did not work and
that that leads to Devin Haney still
being fresh now while cam Bose has used
all that energy to get inside and didn't
work
he has to work on Perry and and some
people aren't comfortable with Perry
all right so Devin Haney throws a double
jab right hand over the top left hook
and he keeps back him out backing him
out with the jab right hand
from Devin Haney circles out
from around the Jab
all right oh overhand right from uh
Devin Haney
jab double jab from Devin Haney
he needs to land a hard shot on camposis
right now it's cambos is through a oh
nice right hand from Devin Haney
camboces through a left hook to Devin
Haney's body but it didn't have the
power on it right now they're holding
each other
referee breaks him up
the last thing to go on cambosis would
be his legs
to be honest with you
very good footwork
left hook from Devin Haney
as Campbell systems backing up cambosis
has good footwork moving from left to
right he's giving him a lot of faints
but he's not working off of his faints
cambosis is Devin Haney's in the center
to the ring
jabbing working off of anything that
camposis is willing to show
overhand right from Devin Haney as he
steps out oh camposis catches Devin
Haney with a left hook all right good
that's something to wake Devin Haney up
because he got lethargic he got into a
routine
all right
jab from Devin Haney right hand from
Devin Haney oh I think he cut put a cut
over the eye of cambosis
yeah I think there's a cut over the eye
of camposis right now from a right hand
from Devin Haney Devon Haynes back with
the Jab
good jab from Devin Haney
Devon Haney tried to uppercut from a jab
in the center of the Ring
good job from Devin Haney Campos has cut
this distance through a left [ __ ]
mist
good jab from Devin Haney anything
gamboces does Devin Haney stops him with
a good jab right hand
oh good jab from Devin Haney overham
right hand right hand oh good left hook
to the body from cambosis to a left hook
to the face to cambosa's on Devin Haney
good stuff
good job from Devin Haney Cambo since
his cutting distance but he's not making
Devin Haney pay
three oh good left hook right hand
from cambosa's nice work from cambosa's
cambos is trying to put something
together
Devin Haney is working but cambosis put
together a good body of work
still didn't win the round too many
right hands from Devin Haney Devin Haney
put a cut over their eye from a clear
right hand definitely good explosion is
it a cut let me see can I see it let me
tell
no it was it it was just oh okay it was
a cut under the eye
but it's just uh it's it's it's a minor
cut that's a it's a good swelling
thank you Kenny
all right so we have a cut on the eye of
Devin the minor cut
in the corner oh beautiful left hook
from camposis
and he missed the other left hook
beautiful stuff
let folk to the body from camboses
looking at the the instant replays
so Devin looks like he's in more control
than he was the first fight
right
okay we in round number nine
and then sent to the ring oh right hand
and a left hook camboston throws the
left hook Devin hey throws a right hand
they both land uh Devin Haynes takes a
step back cambosa's takes a step back
they're both back at it left hook from
Devin Haney
in the center of the Ring
here we go again
back in the center of the Ring everybody
got this little nervous energy nobody
wants to lead everybody wants to take
what the other one is given so nothing
is being thrown
both is playing Counter puncher right
now all right well cambosa steps up and
he tries to take it to Devin Haney
he cuts the distance but he cut he
smothered his shots
all right let's go Devin Haney has a cut
on his eye right now that has to be from
that love hook that uh cambos is through
Devin Haney's throwing a jab Cambo since
he's talking hella crap right now
Devin Haney's back to jabbing through
the right hand
bosus is talking so much crap
all right Devin Haney throws a jab Knox
Campos is off his Square camposis throws
over hand right misses
good jab from uh Devin Haney
Cambo says a circle and circling like a
hobby shock he wants to jump all over uh
Devin Haney
beautiful stuff oh right hand from
camboces I think he got Devin hey oh
right here from Devin Haney oh
yo that was a good sequence they both
exchanged right hands but I think Devin
hey I mean uh cambos's right hand was a
little bit sweeter oh he exploded
exploded cambo's eye Cambo says I has
exploded Devin Haney with that right
hand has exploded cambo's eye I'm
talking about that one hit a quitter
that boom boom bang that thing that you
want to see he painting his face red
that jab is all over it looks nuts folks
I'm not even gonna lie oh my God that
right hand he woke Devon Haney up he
shouldn't hit him with that right hand
that right hand and made this man crazy
this man and threw a right-hand left
hook this man is throwing a sharp jab it
looked like he's throwing a razor blade
he's cutting his face wide open this is
nuts can't believe it right now cam
bosses tried to rush Devin Haney Devin
Haney through a jab just stop him oh man
you want to cut distance right now you
better stay in there that one to three
range boy right now this is kind of
terrible round is over that was what I'm
talking about this is what prize
fighting is about both men giving and
taken but one man took a lot
the side of his head is exploded Devin
Haney hit him so hard that the eye blew
up on this side and the side of his head
blew up on that side this is wild
absolutely wild stuff if you're gonna
look at it go back and look at it he
caught him with the right hand the side
of his head exploded I don't know what
the hell is going on on the side of his
head he looked like he got a little hand
reaching out saying please get me out of
here this is absolutely nuts oh
my God that right hand and a left hook
Devin Haney is being a monster on this
guy straight jab stop cambosis in his
track camposis was coming in Devin Haney
stopped him so get out of here with that
we ain't taking that today get out of
here gave it the office this is not what
you're looking for right now they're
about to get it in again Devin Haney had
his best round of the fight and these
dudes definitely are in it
look at that size of that what is that
vaseline on the side of that guy's head
oh buddy right there it's a beautiful
jab from Devin Haney Devin Haney gambos
has got his neck tucked in
he's not trying to catch that work oh
man Devin Haney right now is hunkering
in jab is coming from his chest instead
of his leg he's zeroing in on his job
he's aiming his jab left hook right
there beautiful stuff right hand from
Devin Haney uh oh left hook right hand
from Devin Haney again Devin Haney is
coming in pause
good jab right hand left hook from Devin
hey oh can both his legs don't look good
Devin Haney go for The Knockout boys
let's get it boys let's get it got
campuses against the roof oh man your
legs don't look good baby let's go right
hand from Devin Haney Devin Haney hook
to the body oh left hook right hand
let's go oh Karen bosus is still here
boy oh right hand over the top
definitely ain't he said oh he he faked
him left to the body left hook to the
head oh left hook right hand
damn whoa right hand from Devin Haney
beautiful stuff jab is looking good boy
looking fantastic out here oh right hand
over the side and said man if you don't
get up and stop this fight good god oh
jab
stepping all over him right now here we
go Devin Haney tried to end it with that
left hook he threw another left hook cam
BOCES with all heart he is fighting I am
not gonna lie he got blood streaming out
his head his ears his eyes and his nose
oh man let's go let's go oh he punches
Devin Haney in the stomach Devin Han he
takes a step back camboces is still
trying to fight Devin Haney throws a
right hand over the top this is Sinister
folks this is Sinister Devin Haney is
walking this man down beautiful left
hook on the inside
oh man right hand right hand when are
you gonna stop it when are you gonna do
the main thing and stop it right now
when are you gonna do me anything this
man don't got his legs and then oh left
hook he threw a beautiful last [ __ ] that
would have stopped him but he didn't
right now Devin Haney ate that love Hook
from cam BOCES right hand from uh Devin
Haney cambosis is clapping his gloves
together he threw a left hook Devin
Haney ate that cambosis is still there
eye streaming headstream and eyes
streaming camposis no streaming right
now he looks like a kid for the kleenex
commercial somebody gets some tissue
mopped this dude up what's going on here
Campbell's sister still fighting back
referee is going to break them up
because they're in a clinch
the most dominant round of the whole
fight folks the most dominant round of
the whole fight Devin Haney the
Undisputed Champion right now is showing
you exactly why he's Undisputed because
if you're trying to dispute that round
folks you're absolutely crazy there's no
dispute in those left hooks right hands
that he gave that man right there he
looks like one of those blotter marks
what his face looked like roshak this is
ridiculous
laughs
[Laughter]
cambos is looking like he's just below
Haney's level touching the distance but
Karen out yeah that's right one away
dragons what's going on brother
beautiful stuff look at that
they showing the replays right now man
I'm not gonna front this stuff gets you
adrenaline popping this is what boxing
is about this is what you stay up for
this is what you try to see this is the
stuff that you want to see
all right so they're taking camboses
over to to look at the referee I mean to
look at the doctor the doctor's like man
get in there let them fight now I like
old school stuff
let them bleed
oh man here we go camposis is back in
the middle of the Ring God bless his
heart
[Laughter]
we're in round 11. this is the
championship rounds right now camposis
throws a 1-2 while he doubles up on the
jab there was a double jab right hand
and misses both all right
Devin Haney's keeping his hands close
now you know when he's keeping his hands
close he's Sharp Shooting he's keeping
his jab close he's trying to land
something that can rattle uh camposis
right hands right hands to the side of
Cam Bose's head
camposis throws two body shots to kind
of low but it doesn't matter referee
warns them keep your hands up
that's what he should do keep your hands
up
left hook from Devin Haney to the body
right hand to Devin Campbell's body from
uh Devin Haney jab from Devin Haney
right hand in close referee comes in
separates the two
right back at it
Devin Haney comes in throws the overhand
right catches camboces real close nice
jab from Devin Haney camposis throws a
jab and a left hook off the jab double
hand he comes back with two Jabs of his
own camposis throws a right hand to the
body misses he goes to South Pole right
now and he switches right back because
Devin Haney throws a jab to freeze him
right hand oh double left hook left hook
from uh Devin Haney
Campbell's throws a double left hook
before that uh can't uh
oh cambosis right now lunges in with a
left hook and then it has to separate
the two
Devin Haney's back to jabbing in the
center of the ring cambosis is jabbing
as well right hand from Devin Haney on
the side of cambosa's head
back to the center to the ring
left hook right hand from Devin Haney
right hand from Cambo says on the
shoulder of Devin Haney he switches and
cuts distance but throws a left hook
that's what he was supposed to be doing
earlier he didn't do that Campbell's eye
is back to streaming again
oh right hand from Devin Haney on that
stream and uh he's streaming on Twitch
[Laughter]
my God devastating right hand from Devin
Haney cambocious is holding he's looking
for the referee he's like man please get
this dude off of me
Devin Haney leaps in with a uppercut
left hook
right hand left hook cambosis is still
fighting you gotta love the heart on
this kid because this kid don't got no
quit that's right he stays right there
he throws a left hook he throws another
left hook he throws another left hook
missed all those left hook but he tried
cambos is dead round is over we're going
to the last round folks this is where
Amanda made and babies are put away time
to go to sleep this is exactly what we
was coming in for I told you 12 rounds
I'm thinking with 12 rounds this is 12
rounds this is what we get this is what
we got
oh Devin Haney you have showed Leaps and
Bounds more than you showed in the first
fight was it possible
yes it is
well he was camposis thinking this was
gonna happen did he know that he had
another level
boom dear God
he hit him with that right oh and the
left hook will all right so he leaps in
with his right hand Devin Haney does
Campbell said oh my God those two body
shots but then uh Devin Haney throws
this left hook from the gods
kind of crazy
something sinister
boy this is this is why God doesn't give
dudes boxing ability and Power
something scary to see
all right so last round
here we go
again both sisters is coming out he's
telling them come on man
you got to give cambosis his credit man
you know the dude has the heart of a
champion he's willing to fight Devin
Haney is circling the ring
you know cambosis is trying to push the
fight camposis knows that you know his
his
only chance right now is a knockout and
um
he's coming that Devin Haney but Devin
Haney is circling Cambo says is missing
he missed the left hook Devin Haney is
just moving from side to side
um you know jabbing spurringly little
right hands here and there Step In step
out it just count to measure the type of
things because it is the last round
he grabs Devin uh camboses
you know steps over
camposis throws an inside left hook and
misses he throws a right hand
misses
camposis is saying come on he's tapping
his gloves together come on come on
Devin Haney throws a jab
I don't think devonaney wants to you
know knock him out
camposis throws a right hand left hook
Devin Haney I mean cambosis is really
trying to be honest with you but Devin
Haney is not throwing any shots
at all throws a jab here and there
camposis Cuts distance Devon and he
pushes him off
Devin Haney is moving in and out
and he throws a right hand catches
camposis
throws a left hook
throws a right hand catches camboces
the cambosis is still trying to fight
camposis throws a 1-2 to Devin Haney's
body right now uh cambosis is winning
this round in my opinion
he steps over
his eyeball is bleeding again
you know camposis is hunting him throws
up a cut
those right hand and camboses wants to
fight
you know you got 37 seconds left
in the round
you know cambosis is trying
but um he's moving from left to right
and
trying to cut distance with Devin Haney
throws over him right you know right to
the eye again
21 seconds left
you know
referee breaking them up 14 seconds left
Devin Haney is moving from side to side
another great fight from Devin Haney
uh beautiful stuff let me just check and
see
if the other fight
is ready to be started
come back when we get the official word
but man Devin Haney put on a performance
all right so the Deontay Wilder fight is
getting ready to start
all right so that fight is getting ready
to start
let me uh
get back to
the fishing call
and tell us what the official word is
and I'll let y'all know
it was um so was it worth it hell yeah
it was worth it Haney was definitely
worth it um
he showed something different you know
um he showed that he could take a punch
because he he got hit with a couple of
shots this fight and he showed that he
was able to deliver some shots I think
sometimes that we want somebody to be
something that they're not and I already
know who Devin Haney is so I don't
expect him to be overnight Javonte uh
Davis I don't expect him to be Ryan
Garcia
Ryan Garcia
is exactly
what I like in a boxer reminds me of De
La Hoya I've always told y'all that
he has that pop
he has to get you out of there Devin
Haney had a couple of instances in this
fight if he had that pop that gets you
out of there cambosis would not be
around but Devin Haney would be a
complete fighter he would be a complete
fighter because he has the footwork he
has the boxing ability you know um he
has the IQ the ring IQ so if if he was
to have that pop on his punches
um my God like he would be the complete
fighter he would be uh the Sugar Ray
Robinson of our time I thought sugary
Robinson was an insane fighter he just
you know speed level and and boxing IQ
and power all rolled up into one that
was like God in the person you know in
in the boxing ring you know Sugar Ray
Robinson uh was in my opinion the the
greatest living embodiment of the boxing
sport itself you know the guy is
something to behold of something insane
all right his record was something
insane bananas
um so I think Devin Haney showed a lot
tonight I showed I think he showed a lot
more than he had before
um
uh and and
cambosis showed me a lot a lot of
graciousness right like at the end
shaking giving you know giving them
praise you know
um this this is what I'm talking about
this is what I'm talking about respect
and somebody else in your country that
you you want somebody to feel welcome in
your home that that's what I'm talking
about you know Win Lose or Draw this is
a sport you earn money together this is
this is a bond this is something that
somebody can never take away from you
you've put your heart on the line and
everything there so
um this is beautiful stuff to see
hold on
a unanimous decision
all right and still
all right so let's go
let's go to the Deontay Wilder fight
I'm predicting a fifth round knockout
um anything less your man over trained
to be honest with you
I say that a lot right
all right
all right so Deontay Wilde is walking
out right now so that means helenius has
walked out already so he's coming out in
the black and gold iron Lord colors me
if I like that man if I like that man if
I like that a lot
let me see would love to know what you
thought about Johnny tell uh tapio was a
family friend
oh uh Johnny Tapia was this man what was
I mean um okay I think uh
we all know drug use uh stunted his
boxing career
if not for that
the man had the boxing ability to power
the IQ in the heart to be in the mix
with everybody else
um but um the the drugs actually just
did them um type Dirty you know Deontay
Wilder has a ponytail like a samurai
and he comes in in Spartan clothes so he
looks like God of War right now to be
honest with you yeah
he looks like God of War
so um looks really good
it has a ponytail let's see what's gonna
happen here
he doesn't have one of that heavy stuff
stuff that he was complaining about
before
I want to know
um
how he moves in the ring he looks
smaller right and I'm talking about
muscle wise
so
we have Deontay
I don't know man I have mixed feelings
about
when
uh veteran Fighters fight
s that
I I say is beneath them not beneath them
but um no fight is beneath anybody but
fights that aren't worthy of their Focus
right
now let's say he's going to be getting a
Payday for his longtime sparring partner
that he loves his family he's he's come
to see his family as his little daughter
comes over and watches him Spar and he
says listen man I got a great idea go
out and when you're fighting then the
next fight I'll call you out and then we
can get this money together and you know
all that money that I couldn't pay you
in sparring you can get that in this
fight and you can get this payday
because who's giving Robin helenius a
fight right who's going to give Robin
Elena's a title fighter who's gonna get
Robin and lean is a top billing right
it's foreign partner to do that you know
I'm gonna put you in I'm gonna give you
some bread I'm gonna get you some bread
I'm gonna get some eyes and some focus
on you
I think that's good
um
can I go wrong
can that go drastically bad
can that be something that
comes back and bites Deontay Wilder
you know because this is a big man
that he's fighting
would he get flashbacks to Tyson Fury
because uh Robert hellenius looks uh
surprisingly like uh Tyson Fury
so could he get hit and get your
disoriented and catch a flashback of
Tyson Fury
we never know
I got five rounds
so helenius looks like he's in shape for
his uh his size his record is 31 with
three losses and 20 knockouts
all right so
very good
very good top knight sparring thoughts
and top-notch Guy
didn't bring a bum to your camp
but does he lack the foot movement yeah
probably so
subliminal butt whipping
he was definitely crazy uh Johnny tapio
was
all right so Deontay Wilder's record is
42 with two with one draw with 41
Knockouts brother
that means
he has the greatest knockout to
professional record ratio
of anybody current and I think of the
past as well
42 with 41.
two losses right
that means one of those dudes
out of those victories
didn't get knocked out
that means the high likelihood of you
catching these hands and getting
sprawled out in the middle of the Ring
is very very high
this man is a destruction a destructive
force of human nature
something scary
something absolutely frightening
Mike Tyson didn't even do that
you're gonna argue Mike Tyson fought
better competition but
you fight who you get in front of you
right
the record is
by who you put in front of you so
Trevor burbick was a mean man but um
Mike Tyson showed otherwise right
we got 51 people here we got 64 likes
man I love you boy
all right Deontay looks dry
that's one thing I don't like I don't
like when Fighters come out and they
don't look already oiled up
pause
round starts
all right so you have
um
Robin throws a right hand catches
Deontay deante takes a step back deante
looks really skinny man
really really really skinny his back
looks really small
um helenius hits him with a right hand
again
and Deontay takes a weird turn
and then it's a stalking him the bigger
dude is helenius
bigger by far
okay
and the answer is not pushing Deontay
looks
really weird
really weird really sluggish really
weird
he's throwing the Jab
steps over
elenius is uh
jabbing to deonte's body
Deontay
faded took a faint back
from a punch I don't know this this
round is really weird Deontay is
circling around helenius
while he's throwing Jabs
and Helen is just throwing to deonte's
body
Deonte is giving up a lot of ground he
throws a wild right hand and misses
helenius
over the top
terrible right hand to be honest with
you
yeah I think that was the Jab
and helenius is stalking him
taking him over to the corner
deontay's circling
hmm
very different very different take on
the Deontay Wilder fight he looks very
slow
very slow
he got pushed back
he looks slow and weak Deontay Wilder
does
slow and weak
because Helen he has pushed them back
good body shot from helenius
Deonte throws a jab till any of his face
Deontay looks like he doesn't have his
feet under him
I don't know his legs looks extra skinny
I don't know
he's bouncing from corner to corner
throws a jab
he punched helenius in the face and
dropped him
oh hell no
what the hell just happened
he punched helenius in the face
yo he punched helenius in the face and
dropped him
in the first round I gotta see that I
gotta see the punch over
I got to see the I gotta see the punch
over
I gotta see the punch over because the
fight is over
the fight is over
the fight is over
the fight is over now I gotta see the
punch over before I call this before I
call BS before I yell out BS
I got I gotta I gotta see the punch over
before I say
out of here
before I say
out of here
I got it I gotta see the poncho
show me the replay man
because I'm sitting here watching it
just like you
and I'm guarding them
I swear to God you smell like
yes
I gotta see it though
can't call it yet though
I gotta see it though
buddy buddy
boy
fix
fix
you gotta work on that better WWE sell
it better than that I gotta see it again
this dude's still in now
it's like he put a brick in his face
get the hell out of here
yo listen I know he has God power
but usually you wind it up you don't
punch from your nipple and knock
somebody out if I'm punching for my
nipple I'm getting in the ring right now
let me see this
he hit him hard but not like that though
it looked clean though but not like not
coughing clean
was it coughing clean come on man was it
coughing clean
was it was it rapping put him in a
casket clean once he put him in a casket
clean man
oh man oh man what's it put it in a
casket clean though was it knock a
booger clean did a booger come out his
nose clean was it that type of clean man
come on man if you're gonna sell it sell
it man don't sell it like that man
come on man
come on man
it's more important buddy
you're sparring partner buddy
come on man
did I see a booger fly out his nose man
no I ain't see a booger fly you know
when somebody got hit with a booger fly
come on man
come on man yeah come on man no boogers
man
I don't see no but he yo I ain't gonna
forget that man an award the best actor
of the year award look at this man just
like how we practice it now you're gonna
come in with your leg up lean your head
out I'ma hit you here oh God I did I'm
alive I did I'm alive I'm dead I'm dead
I am not gonna lie [ __ ] thank you Devin
Haney and Kim bosses for putting it all
on the line not bringing spawn Partners
into the mix
your man said yeah
oh I'm gonna I'm gonna lay down over
here
come on man
oh man Deontay come on man
well folks
I'm Gonna Leave y'all with
some real
fights to look at at the outro
this is Wilder have anyone the most
powerful luck in the boxing History
Bruce Lee had that kind of punch you
know
[Laughter]
yo Manny was still on a map man
yo man
he said do you have to Wanda got Bruce
Lee power
he said
wow Bruce Lee one inch power
get out of here
oh my God
oh thank you guys
fantastic stuff
watch the outro man
oh
I can't lie man you can't write a better
script
thank y'all for hanging out with Lord
King David the professional fan watch
style troll guys
[Music]
[Music]
might lose
[Music]
if you really want it in the ring I
don't send the contract out knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a Viper ain't no competition in
the ring of sight because I'm spitting
phenomenal swinging fire talking pickled
peppers make them pay the piper cause I
might go live like a rude discussion and
deflate your chest like a food reduction
you be talking like you wanna do
concussions and I do to custom attitude
adjustments these are fighting words
better give me that respect that I
deserve for another knuckle sandwich
even got his winning only homie Kevin
you a phony homie now you owe me action
happens thinking Tony Toni Braxton and
they all want to talk for attention but
the fame only lasts for an instant mama
got hands doing bread for the pension
imma leave them red You Can Dance
[Music]
foreign